and do some quick introductions I think
that'd be really helpful because there's
quite a few of us here today which is
really positive and so thanks for
attending my name is um Jane Slater I'm
a counselor in Stratford and Humphrey
Park Ward and I'm also the exec member
for
um I was going to say health wellbeing
inequalities but that was last year it's
Health and Care this year thank you
good morning everyone I'm Nathan
Atkinson I'm the corporate director for
adults and well-being here at Trafford
camps
good morning everyone Gareth James
Deputy police lead for Health and Care
integration
hey good morning everyone um Alex Murray
governance officer
Morning Joe Bryan from the public health
Team and I lead on Tobacco Control and
pharmacies which is why I'm here today
[Music]
hi my name's Rose Thompson I'm a
counselor in Brooklyn's in sale and I'm
also the accept member for communities
in safety
I'm Emma hodgkinson the public health
commissioning manager
um as of Monday this week I'm going to
start picking up some of the Tobacco
Control work so that's why I'm here
today
hi everyone I'm Kate shetwood and I'm a
new Public Health consultant in the
public health team in the council thank
you
first one to fail good morning
George Devlin from Trafford Community
Collective represent the voluntary
Community faith and social Enterprise
sector in Trafford
uh Manish Prasad I'm a gpiba background
and I'm the associate medical director
for Trafford greater Manchester
integrated care
morning Harry Callahan governance
officer
one in Richard Royal corporate director
for place at Trafford Council
hi everyone I'm Nat McGregor and I'm
doing work experience with the council
this week
and hi everyone I'm Caroline siddle I'm
the housing strategy and growth manager
at the council and new to the board and
will be represented in housing and
housing strategy thank you
good morning Alicia Smith I'm detective
superintendent based over at Trafford at
the Stratford police station I'm here on
behalf of collect Rose who's the chief
superintendent
morning everyone Thomas Maloney program
director across Health and Care and a
joint appointment between NHS greater
Manchester and Trafford Council
good morning I'm Caroline Davidson I'm
one of the director of strategy at mft
[Music]
good morning everyone I'm Richard
spearing I'm managing director of
Trafford lco and I'm here representing
Casey Calvin Thomas Who's chief
executive Manchester and Trafford lcos
morning all I'm Heather Fairfield and
I'm the chair of healthwatch Trafford
one I'm Jane Wayman I'm a GP and
Amsterdam representing the GP board
morning everyone I'm Bernie Tomlinson
the West area enabled engagement
coordinator working under Trafford local
Care Organization
Kate McAllister Public Health
intelligence lead for traffic Council
thank you everybody and
welcome like I said and so if we can
move on with the agenda if we can have a
look at the minutes from the last board
and can we agree these as a correct
um
or if there any issues anybody's got any
amendments or anything can we agree
these there's
yep thank you very much
and then if we move on to any
Declarations of Interest
just guys yeah thanks Jay not a
declaration of interest just to go back
to the minutes it was just a matter of
rising on number six straight on Return
of the reference and the second
um item that was resolved there is an
action so so you have several
discussions around the vice chair have
taken place and we'll bring that back to
the next meeting so it hasn't been
resolved but I think you'll be nowhere
we're going so so we'll bring that back
next meeting thank you thanks Gareth
um do we have any questions from the
public
Alex none have been received thank you
so if we can move on to the GM joint
forward plan and that's going to be a
double act I understand between Gareth
and Tom so over to you gamma thank you
thanks chair so I'll kick off on that
Tom is here and other members from the
locality team so so just a few
introductory comments hopefully we'll
have some time for discussion rather
than just Tom and I presenting so
hopefully people have a chance to have a
look at the document that we shared just
to recap quickly the the newly formed
integrated care boards have a duty to
produce a five-year delivery plan so
that's described now as a joint forward
plan so that will detail how the
strategy will be delivered but also how
we'll undertake the statutory duties of
the uh the ICB at the integrated care
board so previously at the health and
wellbeing board we've shared the draft
versions of the joint forward plan and
we brought those here for discussion and
the last meeting we had a good
discussion I think I think that if the
board felt that in the document was
really helpful documented included all
of the right things it made perfect
sense it was just a some frustration I
guess that you know we needed to move to
see more delivery some clear actions of
delivery of the strategy service so I
think
the current version that we share you
know the published version it does start
to do that so I think our role now is to
understand what that means for our
locality plans so both the Trafford
locality plan but also you know the
health and well-being strategy you know
that we've agreed here and so
Tom has shared some really helpful
questions on the front sheet there so so
it would be helpful if we could come
back to to discuss some of those and
I'll go back to those just just in a
second just to recap what the main areas
of the plan are so what now are
described as emissions so the six
missions hopefully people have seen so
to strengthen the communities to help
people stay well and detect
their illness earlier to help people to
get into and staying good work
to to continue the recovery of the core
NHS and care services to support our
Workforce and carers and then to Achieve
Financial sustainability just thrown in
at the end there so so you know some
really helpful areas there for each of
those in the document then you'll see
that now there are some clear sort of
areas of focus and some key areas
for delivery and action plans and there
are many conversations now across GM
with all Partners to move to that
delivery phase so what we thought we
would spend some time chair if that's
okay to go back to the questions that
Tom has posed in the cover paper
that we've shared with the papers just
to go through and it's
about really seeing how the joint
forward plan now fits in to to the
health and well-being board priorities
you know that we've agreed following the
Deep guys and to to evidence or start to
think how we will evidence you know that
we are making a difference against those
things
just to say Thomas started to undertake
in quite a detailed piece of work to go
through the documents in its entirety
and cross-reference happening so where
it says locality or it says health and
well-being board to do that piece of
work so that's quite a detailed lengthy
piece of work but I think if we could
have a brief discussion here today that
will help with that piece of work moving
forward so I'll pause there Tom I don't
know if there's anything else you wanted
to say by a way of introduction or do we
want to go straight into discussion I
think we can probably go straight into
discussion guide there's probably not
much more to to add I think um people's
abusing opinions on how the health and
well-being board can drive forward some
of the priorities of the joint forward
Plan and there's there's absolute
obvious Synergy in certain places with
the health and well-being board strategy
and the Deep dive
um action plans one of which we're
hearing about today later on in the
agenda so yeah I think just open it up
for that initial conversation really
thank you
thanks Tom thanks Gareth I think that um
some of the stuff that in the joint
forward plan I think one one of the
items that have come out of it that I'm
really Keen to um make sure is shared as
widely as possible is is about residents
knowing where to go and I think that you
know if we can get residents to go to
the right place at the you know at the
right time it then actually prevents and
quite some substantial impact on on the
acute system so I think that's for me
knowing where to go is um you know is
one of our it is one of the priorities
that have come out of the joint forward
plan so if anybody's got any
contributions I'm really happy to start
the conversation so
anybody want to say anything
go go
yeah I think looking at the forward view
all all roads in many ways lead to the
neighborhoods you know in terms of the
priorities and I think the the work
that's going to go on through through
the provided collaborative
an expertly LED by a lot of people
around this table
um will really contribute to those
priorities whether it's people living
well at home managing conditions links
to hospital at home so I think the the
kind of enabled model is absolutely the
heart of that and I know one of the key
things we want to do with that is
identify those really core priorities
but most importantly the measures of
success as well
um
and and that's absolutely critical
I think you know Nathan's completely
right about the neighborhood plan I
think we also need to be really mindful
of the the work that's been done by the
poverty truth commission and the four
recommendations we had a really positive
conversation at the Trafford partnership
last week where I think we've almost
agreed that those four recommendations
provide a foundation for whatever we're
doing and I think we need to clearly
link those conversations the four
recommendations into the work of the
health and well-being board and Link
that into the forward plan and again I
think it's around how we demonstrate the
outcomes and how we demonstrate the
achievements particularly with that
Focus around Health inequalities
but I suppose we have got a really good
opportunity there because it's already
embedded in different parts of the
system
[Music]
thanks
um yeah I think this is a really
um sticky issue isn't it across greater
Manchester and thinking about what's the
role of the health and wellbeing board
and then what's the role of the other
groups and Partnerships and strategies
that are going on in the local reality
in terms of contributing to this quite
broad GM forward plan and I think that
um doing the exercise that you started
talking about mapping
how trafford's already
dug into its needs thought about its
priorities worked with Partners to
identify what those are mapping where
they fit already will probably show that
we're already on with quite a lot of
this this stuff and we need to kind of
use that to prioritize
um I think the the one of the challenges
would be dealing with things that
clearly are of interest to the health
and well-being board and locality board
and probably others
um I think there's a really interesting
question about what happens whether
where there's gaps in terms of there's
something in the June fraud plan that we
haven't identified as a priority in
either the author being bored or a culti
board or any of those structures because
that might be really legitimate
prioritization exercise that we've done
because it is a huge plan and I don't
know how that then plays with with the
GM colleagues because obviously some
things will happen at that level but I
think that maybe it is for this board to
think about being brave enough to say
we're going to we're going to prioritize
and focus on these things because that's
what trafford's been working on it's
what you know for example the poverty
choose Commission shown us we've got our
health and well-being board priorities
which map very clearly to this as you
say
um and then there's things like housing
in there that you know that actually
maybe we just need to bring more to the
fourth who in in this board's work so I
think the mapping will tell us a lot
including gaps and overlaps what we do
then with some of those I think will be
the next question
um but I do think we maybe should be
brave enough to say we're not we're not
going to try and have a response to all
of this and increase our priorities to
70 or whatever
[Music]
yeah thanks I think that's really
helpful isn't it you know to stick into
what we've agreed are the priorities for
traffic I think that once we have
completed that work you know there will
be some gaps you know so you know we
mentioned so many times as a locality
throughout the document I think I think
though that you know there are huge
synergies between what we've agreed as
the main priorities with all six of
those missions I think you know that you
could weave them all in to all six of
those so so I don't think even though
there might be some some specific gaps
in terms of some of the terminology I
think that we can sort of demonstrate
that if
other priorities we've agreed do fit
into those so so I think that piece of
work is crucial what I was going to
suggest perhaps chair if we bring that
piece of work back once we've done that
because I think it'll need to go through
locality board but you could also come
back here so that we can sort of you
know tie those connections together
thank you
thank you um yeah so just building on
that I think there's some real tangible
examples within the giant followed plan
of of um of work that that we have
ongoing in in the locality it doesn't
necessarily feed into to here as a
health and well-being board and it
doesn't necessarily sit within the
Trafford locality board as well but it
sits in other forums be that a council
specific one it might be something that
tlco or one of our NHS partners are
driving forward
um so it is about the coordination of
some of that work and and having it fed
through so we can go back to George's
original point which was have we made a
difference and what are the outcomes
from these pieces of work that we've
we've got in train and they'll there may
well be um some gaps but I think the
majority of it is uh is in hand and
happy to share that work and bring that
back in in September really positively I
think there's some really good enabling
um elements of the giant followed plan
so the focus on social value I know
that's really important here in traffic
and I'm part of the social value
Steering group and the action plan that
we have here
um so fantastic to see that around the
good employment chart to the tripatha
housing agreement so it all starts to
bring it back through here which affects
the prevention agenda which we're
obviously very strong on and through the
health and wellbeing board strategies so
um yeah
at the end of the discussion at the
integrated partnership
um board about the joint forward plan
um there was quite a strength of feeling
that what had not really been included
was sufficient Focus was around children
and mental health
um and
um
from the meetings that I attend
um the children's
focus is really gaining an awful lot of
strength and particularly uh cams and
we're hearing now of literally hundreds
of children who can't have their needs
addressed
um and I would hope that that would be
something that the health and wellbeing
board
um could pick up on thanks
uh can everyone hear me okay
yeah right uh so my name is Kent
McAllister I work in the public health
intelligence team at Trafford Council
and I'm briefly going to talk to you
today about using census data to help
shape questions around Public Health
within Trafford
so the aims of this are to describe some
of the features of the 2021 census we're
not going to go through every single uh
question that was in it
um to outline the benefits and
challenges of using this data resource
to support Public Health activities and
to seek input from the board in relation
to prioritization of topic areas for
exploration of resources so
um we could do loads and loads of work
with the census we could come up with
hundreds and hundreds of different
analyzes but obviously there are key
priorities that this board would have we
need to make sure that we focus our
efforts on questions that you are
collectively wanting answered
so if you're not familiar with the
census it covers a broad range of topics
I mean you you probably will have filled
it in yourself but not maybe thought
about it as a data resource so it tells
us about the populations and households
we have within our local communities and
the household composition so it's a way
that we can find out how many
single-person households there are how
much intergenerational living there is
as well
it can tell us a bit about the health of
people so there's some self-reported
health questions about um how people
regard their health and well-being it
can tell us how um what level of
Education that people have
whether they have any disabilities in
line with the disability equalities Act
uh whether they are undertaking any
unpaid care
what country they were born in what
their ethnicity is their language and
religion their sexual orientation and
their gender identity
so you can see that there are questions
here that will give us some insights so
that we can quantify so that we can
count how many people within our
community
um have certain attributes and that
might help us in the planning and
delivery of services
so it's got really a lot of really
useful features so you'll often hear
data people talk about we need more data
and you can't really complain about the
census because it's got 97 coverage at
the England level 98 of the Trafford
level so we've done very well there
has a really robust methodology so the
office for National statistics have been
collecting this data for decades they
really know what they're doing there's a
lot of consistency across key topics so
you can look at changes over time that
said sometimes new questions come in
sometimes definitions have changed but
all of this stuff is really well
documented so people do know how to
handle that that kind of situation
and geography is a really strong benefit
of this data set so quite often people
will come to us and say can you tell us
about you know the rates of this in this
neighborhood or in this world and we
often struggle with data because at best
we can often only get things at the
Trafford level whereas the census
enables us to look at the the ward level
at the the msoa level it's really really
useful it's going to be really helpful
for supporting neighborhood work
so if you want to have a look at the
results for the census for Trafford the
data lab from the business intelligence
team have produced a fantastic range of
resources so if you follow this link and
go to traffic data lab you'll find
infographics like the one I've just
posted there so if you're doing a
presentation and you want to convey
something about the local population you
can there's some resources there you can
just lift straight away and use there's
some longer reports that go into a bit
more detail and there is access to some
of the data itself so if you're that way
minded you can you can play around with
it and and look into it to satisfy some
of your own Curiosities
however it does have some limitations so
a census is what's known as
cross-sectional data it's a single slice
through a population at one point in
time
the consequence of this is it only tells
us about our population on that day so
it can tell us if someone was a carer
that day but not if they stopped being a
carer a month later it can tell us if
someone was unemployed on that day but
not how long they've been unemployed for
or how many times
so this means we can't really use it to
determine cause and effect so we don't
know say if someone has bad health and
they're unemployed are they unemployed
because they've got bad health or do
they have bad health because they're
unemployed we can't tell just from this
data alone
data self-reported and some questions
are open to interpretation so that
question around bad Health that's
something that people are self-rating so
it's not like it's been determined by a
healthcare professional that's not to
say it doesn't have any value because
it's really important for us to
understand how people perceive their own
experiences but it's something where we
might then want to compare that to other
data sources to be sure that that
patterns were consistent because people
answer different questions in different
ways
and we need to avoid overreach so we
could use the data from 2021 to predict
how many three-year-olds there would be
in 2023 based on how many one-year-olds
there were two years ago because most of
the three-year-olds now are just older
children who were around in 2021. we
can't predict how many three-year-olds
there'll be in the year 2030 or 2040
based on this data alone we would need
to bring in other resources other
knowledge
um there's all sorts of other factors
that would go into a prediction like
that so we mustn't over interpret this
data
so how can we use the Census Data to
inform Public Health activity there's a
couple of good approaches we can take so
we have always lots of existing
questions and we could take those and
see if the Census Data is an appropriate
resource for answering that question
whether on its own or in combination
with other data and intelligence
the second approach is we can start with
a day so we can just be exploratory we
can look at it we can make observations
and use these observations to generate
new questions
we can then consider whether the Census
Data provides a complete answer to those
questions or whether quite often we will
have to go and find other sources of
data and intelligence to answer those
questions
what we need to avoid however is sort of
starting with the data with no questions
in mind and jumping straight to some
conclusions so it's it's really really
tempting to say look at a map or a graph
and go oh this looks like this has
changed therefore it must mean this this
and this but if we don't really have a
clear question in mind
um we're not always sure what we're
answering there's a risk that we're
introducing various types of error and
bias I could talk about this for half an
hour you'll be pleased to know I'm not
going to but if anyone's interested in
this topic do come and have a chat
um and we might also miss opportunities
to answer the question in a better way
so I'm just going to give you an example
so here is a a figure that's been
produced by the data lab it's really
really useful to look at so it tells us
of the people within Trafford who have a
disability according to the equalities
Act
how much how many people have their
day-to-day activities limited a lot I
um their disability
so the blue dots are what their value
was in 2011 and the purple dots of value
in 2021
so there's three key observations you
can make from this firstly in every
single area of Trafford
the number of people in this group seems
to have declined since 2020 2011 down to
2021 so there are fewer people in every
area who say that their disability
limits their day-to-day activities a lot
the second observation is that there is
variation
so certain areas of the of Trafford have
higher rates of this than others
and the third thing to observe is that
the change from 2011 to 2021 has also
varied uh in in those two periods so in
some areas it's decreased a lot and in
some areas it's decreased a little
so those are the observations we can
make
highest is in Partington lowest is in
hail the biggest drop was in urmston the
smallest drop was in West simply
but this is something that seems to have
decreased in every single area
those are observations however this
raises various questions
so for example has the percentage of
residents in this category dropped
because things have improved for people
in this group or because there are fewer
people in this group for other reasons
good or bad so if you think about it
people in this group might have been the
most vulnerable to covid and it might
simply be that we have fewer people in
our population who are now in this group
and that's not necessarily a good thing
on a more positive front maybe there has
been some kind of intervention in the
last 10 years that has made things
better for people
so this is an example of why we can't
just jump straight to a conclusion when
we've made an observation about the data
we can then look at individual areas so
we might see that Hartington has the
highest rates but is that because of
some kind of intrinsic factors are the
people there having disabilities that
impact on their life more than in other
areas or is it because of things beyond
their control so if you have a
disability that means you can't drive
the extent to which this limits your
life might depend on whether you live
next to a tram stop or whether you live
in a sort of public transport desert so
we have to understand whether or not the
things that we're seeing are things that
are based at the personal level or at
the community level
and looking at this data it might also
give us some questions around you know
what past interventions have been
provided which support these residents
and how does the data influence how we
design and influence Implement things in
the future so we might know that there's
been something going on in the last 10
years that explains this and that might
help us to try and do more of it in the
future or we might think well it's
worthwhile in some areas and less well
than others so let's you know change
your approach
so really um I'm handing this now over
to to all of you collectively so I
realized that you might not have had a
chance to look at the Census Data itself
and this might be something that you
would want to respond to at a later date
when you have but it would really help
us to provide the most value to this
particular board if we had an
understanding of what kind of what
existing questions you have and what
areas of uncertainty there are where
Public Health looking at the Census Data
might provide some answers to some of
those existing questions
so what were the most useful insights
you had from the previous census and
where might we have expected to see the
most change
and what are our greater greatest areas
of uncertainty that the known unknowns
as it were
so what areas of the census should
Public Health prioritize exploring to
generate new questions and insights you
might think there are things we've never
looked at with Census Data before maybe
now particularly with new programs like
neighborhood program maybe it's really
important that we start looking at some
of these things
and then what wider work programs should
these insights feed into so as I've
mentioned the neighborhood program as
being a prime example
so uh that's where I'd like to leave it
but I'd like to hand it over to to the
board for any comments and questions
information
be asking questions more and
understanding the libraries aren't equal
across chapters so I think that it's
really
not it's not so much a question just as
a comment and I think it goes back to
what we were saying earlier about the
neighborhood work being the foundations
of what we do so it's really important
which I know we are with the public
health team we're putting this into the
neighborhood work and as Nathan said
needing to measure impact so the issues
of concern are things that we don't just
look at but we do something about
from our points of view so it's really
powerful I think
I suppose
um I'd be really interested in the data
around inequality
particularly any changes between 2011
and in the last census because that
could help us in former approach for the
future we've consistently talked and
it's in some of the papers today about
that Relentless Focus around inequality
I think the data really will enable us
to have that focus
and also enable us to have conversations
about where inequality exists will we be
channeling resources into those areas to
minimize it
thanks
[Music]
yeah I think George is absolutely right
and I suppose it kind of cuts across one
of the questions that someone and Gareth
posed
um about capturing inequalities and and
how we're doing something about it um in
the joint forward view I think the bit
for me that is interesting in the sense
is how the boroughs changed over over 10
years so we have more diversity in the
Buddha
um which is positive but we also know we
have an aging
population as well and it's
understanding how that population is
going to age and are they going to age
well or are they going to experience
long-term conditions sooner and I think
it goes back to the point that Richard
made in a new highlighted Kate around
that kind of hyper local data being
really
imperative because it will vary as your
example did from from war to Ward
yeah
thank you Kate I really um I love data
so that was my presentation really
um I think from a housing point of view
I'd be interested to know a little bit
more about sort of housing housing types
and tenures and how that links with
health
um disability and all that stuff I know
that the census provides lots of data
around that so a breakdown of you know
how's how housing and the types of
housing people live in impact on
people's Health particularly around
property conditions and you know the
issues at the moment with the dampen
mold in both social and private sector
properties
just just building on housing as well I
think affordability of housing as well
and whether we can capture that because
I think one of the observations I drew
from looking at the
Census Data was perhaps are we
experiencing
um a climate where younger families are
kind of priced out the borough are found
in a very difficult to to move into
traffic or or critically stay in
Trafford if the Trafford residents and I
think that sort of um linked between
housing health and well-being
employment's absolutely critical
I guess you mentioned it already but um
you talked about how you bring in other
data as well so I was just wondering
what what you can do around that say
looking at triangulating with little
data or you know data from other sources
so that you can have you know broader
insights than just using the center
stage itself sorry if people can't hear
me realize I wasn't talking into the
microphone
yes absolutely it's quite common for us
to you know work with different data
sets together
um we sometimes have issues around
access so working with Hospital data you
sometimes have to be careful about you
know
um we can't necessarily access
individual patient level data so we will
have to go to other people who can
um and then you know ask them to do
things on our behalf because there's
certain types of data that can't be
taken out of particular environments
confidentiality and appropriate use of
data is always at the Key of everything
um but yeah certainly from a statistical
point of view there's nothing stopping
us linking together certain types of
data sources uh we what we normally need
to do is have
um elements that are shared between data
sets so if you've got the postcode of
the person in the census and in you know
the hospital data that's fine
something we have to be a little bit
mindful though is that you know that's
great for answering certain types of
questions but we also have to be aware
of who's not captured within that so if
we focus on Hospital data we might be
missing people who primarily have their
care in community settings in primary
care so it really just depends on which
question we're trying to answer but
absolutely you know a lot of times acute
Hospital data would be the way to go if
it's a question that is related to that
setting
[Music]
um again really useful and each time I
sort of get more information from the
senses it it makes you think differently
um I suppose this might be linked to the
piece of work that Tom's going to bring
back on the joint forward plan and your
question of what more do we want
um I suppose that links in with what the
metrics and the kpis are for the plan
that you also bring back and probably
then thinking on a neighborhood level
um what actual data would help us
um perhaps look differently towards what
we're trying to achieve picking up on
your point around sort of the data you
have access to to do that in a
collaborative way on a neighborhood
level would mean you could bring
different data from different
organizations in an anonymized way but
to perhaps strengthen what the overall
picture might look like for this health
and well-being board
um
my fault
um just one question actually
um because the completion rate on the
consensus is is brilliant 98 percent
um and what we know from it I think
there was 80 different languages
um being spoken when the census
um goes out and I can just think about
reading it for myself does that have the
ability you know because the success
rate is really good at 98 and we often
hear language you know we know it's
barriers I was just wondering whether
there's any additional support or
anything that's put in place to mean
that that census does get completed
where we have the challenge of language
on a day-to-day
so they will have approaches to that I
think they do have the capacity to
deliver the census itself in different
languages and so on and engage with
different communities that said you were
quite correct there's actually a
variation in uptake rates so we might
see 98 overall but it might be the case
that within certain communities in
Trafford or nationally that's not an
equal uptake so there might be some
people who are disproportionately
missing from the Census Data and that
probably would be quite interesting to
know whether it's on reaffirms with
everything we think in the areas that
we're prioritizing
it's a really good point
foreign
great thank you
um so obviously uh smoking and tobacco
has been a key priority for the health
and well-being board for a number of
years rightly so given that smoking is
the leading cause of preventable death
in the UK
um last year the health and well-being
board you did a deep dive into tobacco
and these were the actions that came out
as a result of it which was around
developing a tobacco Alliance that would
report through to the health and
well-being board undertaking the clear
assessment tool which is an
evidence-based approach to Tobacco to
look at how we perform across various
levels to see what our strengths and
opportunities for development are and
then to produce a multi-agency Tobacco
Control plan and a Communications
calendar so I'm here today to just
update you on where we've got to so far
and what the work is that's taken place
around that
so we have established trafford's
tobacco Alliance and it's had its first
meeting relatively recently we had
really good attendance from across a
number of Partners and we have had quite
a good commitment from other partners
that were unable to attend on that day
but are really committed to the program
and so the alliance itself is a
partnership of
um stakeholders that will come together
to give that strategic leadership around
Tobacco Control and to take a whole
system approach and understandably to
look at reducing those inequalities in
health or experienced by some
communities around around tobacco and
smoking and we also need to make sure
that the work supports the greater
Manchester smoke free by 2030 and by
smoke free they mean five percent of the
population smoking and I've listed here
a few of the members of the tobacco
Alliance
we have undertaken the clear assessment
tool which has been really interesting
uh some of them this shows like how well
we're performing so the further out the
red line the better we are in that area
at the moment
um and this is our Baseline so we will
review this on on an annual basis to see
how we've improved so there's some of
those like you can see the one for your
priority indicators well because the
tobacco Alliance hasn't yet met to look
at the data to establish what are our
key priority areas we're obviously not
performing well on that but once we've
done that in September uh that
particular figure will shoot up around
vision and Leadership again once we've
established that Clear Vision and the
strategy and we'll see that figure
increasing planning and commissioning
um we're not too bad at the moment but
when we've got our actual action plan in
place we'll be seeing that increasing
partnership again we did this before we
started the tobacco Alliance so now that
we've got that in place and also some
work that we're doing collaboratively
across greater Manchester and the
governance structures that should be
we'll see that increasing
prevention and some key areas around
this to kind of raise that figure is
around the work around secondhand smoke
and also around young people
um compliance this is around the the
kind of system the systematic way that
we're approaching uh Tobacco Control so
again we'll see that increasing
communication once we have the comms
plan in place later in the year uh we'll
see a rised figure there Innovation and
learning
um again that will be increased by that
kind of work across that Alliance to
share good practice and and work to look
at how we influence each other's plans
around tobacco
cessation and there's a lot of work that
the the government swap to stop scheme
around
um e-cigarettes will be an opportunity
there for us to increase our
opportunities for our um local people to
engage in smoking cessation and also
work around
um making every contact count within a
variety of services I think within
smoking cessation we were quite an early
adopter for e-cigarettes in Trafford so
we saw a lot of success a number of
years ago particularly through Community
Pharmacy where we had a lot of quits and
we're now I think at the point where
we're having to work a lot more with
some very long-term entrenched smokers
so some of those figures
um may be more difficult for us
um prevalence you need to be seeing a
downward Trend and there was also some
work in that area in the assessment
around secondary care and tobacco
enforcement doing deep Dives which would
increase that figure and and quit data
we've been working with oh head around
submissions of some of our data
nationally which will assist with um
that figure as well but that's where we
are as a baseline um for now
we've also undertaken and it's been
circulated to yourselves a updated
smoking needs assessment in Trafford
um we have seen post-pandemic a slight
increase in our adult smoking population
uh both from the general data and also
from GP data we are still um coming in
below the England average which is
around 13
and we perform well compared to to GM we
have a higher smoking figures in areas
like Partington stretford sell more
they're lower in the um South and all
chewingham area so really the North and
the West
um are the the key areas
um we we did see a dip we were down at
kind of nine percent and then we've gone
back up again but the way that this data
was collected during the pandemic
changed they had less face-to-face
interviews more telephone and people are
more likely to
um lie uh on a telephone interview than
they are on a face-to-face so some of
that is difficult to tell because the
method of collection change but I think
we are we have seen a slight increase
post pandemic and we do have to bear in
mind stuff like the GP data it only is
only recorded by 29 of the population so
that's not a full picture it's just the
GB GP data that we happen to have
um smoking at the time of delivery a lot
of work has taken place across um GM
this was as slow shown a downward Trend
right it rose up very slightly from 4.6
to 4.9
um but we are missing quite a lot of
data from the hospitals on this we're
missing 36 of the data so we're doing
some work with them and how that can be
better captured
adults in routine and manual occupations
obviously we're lower than the England
average in our lower three occupational
classes there's quite a link to social
deprivation and we do know
um that there's more you're more likely
to smoke
um the the lower your income level is
we do see much higher rates and people
with substance dependence and also with
people with severe and enduring mental
illness
um about three times uh the rate of the
routine population and obviously about
75 of people in substance misuse
Services also have a mental illness
um so this is a really key area that we
need to be focusing on in Trafford
we've looked at the Young people's
survey and which has shown that three
percent of young people in Trafford are
smoking
um in GM that's about six percent
um and ten percent are regularly vaping
and in GM that's 22
um we've got
um a relatively
um okay figure around 90 of young people
have never tried smoking 77 never tried
a vape
um again that's higher in Greater
Manchester it's 81 and 59.
um our interventions by GP and Pharmacy
so when you go to receive that support
in helping you to stop smoking has
reduced significantly since 2019 we've
seen a real impact uh from the pandemic
in terms of I suppose capacity uh within
GPU practices and across pharmacies and
their ability to carry out enough
interventions for us it's gone it has
gone down a lot so we really want to
look at other creative ways in which we
can increase that and Caroline with the
mention of housing
um yes we we do know that people in
social housing are more likely to have a
lower income they're more likely to have
a long-term illness and disability and
there is obviously a higher proportion
of people smoking within social housing
and within rented compared to owned
homes and mortgage um
oh nice
so the the next steps for us with the
tobacco Alliance is that we've got we're
now looking at the clear assessment that
we've done we're looking at the needs
assessment and our plan is to Target I
mean I think it's fairly self-evident
which priority areas and groups we
should be focusing on and then we need
to come together to produce our vision
our strategy and our action plan so
we've got an away day planned
um for September uh to look at that and
really progress those areas
um so from yourselves here today uh
really it's about kind of noting the
contents of this
um agreeing that governance that the
tobacco Alliance what we've proposed
within its terms of reference is that it
will report through
um here to the health and well-being
board through the health Improvement
subcommittee obviously we've circulated
out the needs assessment to you so it's
about um kind of I guess signing off
that document and providing support to
the tobacco Alliance in ensuring that we
maintain this good representation that
we've seen at this its first meeting and
for Individual Services to contribute to
um those action plans these were the
high impact actions from the deep dive
so I've just highlighted in yellow the
ones that we have now
um after today will have will have
completed
um so we're we're on on our way
um to completing what we were asked to
do
and then really it's just
um some areas that may be worth
discussing around how the health and
wellbeing board helps to ensure that
this area is prioritized and what
opportunities we've got across the
system
um to embed uh smoking cessation and
Tobacco Control how we balance local
priorities with those GM ones and
obviously uh there's some very stretch
resources and capacity but we've got
some really important work to do so it's
how we how we look at that
foreign
um thanks very much so I'm going to
mention neighborhoods again obviously
because I think the data that we've got
is important and I know
um because obviously I do my homework
about the neighborhood information that
in North Trafford particularly is an
area of where we're finding it difficult
to shift some of the smoking habits for
folks so that's particularly important
that we think about how we can
um support that and I know our staff I'm
sure other people's staff here do the
sort of every contact counts type work
but I think with the folk that you're
talking about that's just having an
initial conversation probably requires a
bit more Focus for them and then I'm
just I'm just really interested I was
chatting with Kate and Amy about some
other things yesterday but about the
children's data and I mean I'm I'm a
parent of teenagers but we live just
over
um the border which you'll probably be
glad to hear when I tell you the rest of
the story but um you know 90 children
never tried smoking 73 never Vaped I I I
don't know how we collected the data or
it may be something about the friends of
my teenagers but I don't I don't
personally recognize that but it's
really subjective Joe so just a review
yeah absolutely I mean we are I think
generally as a society within young
people we are seeing a reduction in
smoking and an increase in vaping and
yesterday we did some interviews for
population Health fellow in Trafford
which is going to do a research project
with us to look specifically around
young people and around vaping to try to
understand I mean that's a survey so
young people are very likely to to lie
in a survey and you know not every young
person in Trafford completed that survey
so all data has got its its restrictions
but we're hoping that the work of this
um research project which will start in
September will help us to underco
uncover what those behaviors motivations
around vaping and smoking are whether
vaping does vaping lead to smoking what
the what are the reasons why young
people are vaping
um perhaps doing some look back
exercises with like 20 year olds and 19
year olds why do you think you took it
up why do you think you stopped it to
help to make our interventions then
um much wiser in the future so I think
that will be a really interesting piece
of work and that Trafford will be
leading on
sorry just to
um add on to that so I think it's rare
comment about the Daytona note something
we spoke about yesterday
um like I said picking up this area on
day five so you might have to bear with
me but I met without hid earlier in the
week and kind of my challenge back was
about the data because we're hearing
from elsewhere
like anecdotally you would expect it to
be much higher so I've spoken to oh head
I think we're going to get some kind of
working group together to kind of look
at data specifically in this area so I'm
going to support them with that so just
to
um add that in there and then yesterday
like Joe said we end the interviews
there were great
um and the candidate kind of already
highlighted the issue of like social
desirability and kind of saying what
they think you want to hear
um and they are they said in their
interview kind of ways they would
address it so it's kind of already on
their radar so hopefully when that
pregnant Hotel fellow does come in
starting in September and it'll bring
something really good local if I was in
Trafford
okay
thank you yeah um thanks Joe really
interesting and as you said majority of
those that are smoking are living in in
Social affordable housing I know we
tried to engage with some housing
associations and organize a meeting and
it wasn't particularly successful so
maybe we need to have another
conversation about how we can do that
and maybe how you link in with existing
groups where could they come to and then
there's an agenda about smoking smoking
cessation on the rather than organizing
a specific meeting just about that but
we can touch about that because
obviously I've got those links with all
the housing associations and I think
they're being a key partner to this I am
engaging with those tenants that are
smoking yes so we have had some interest
from great places in terms of
establishing a pilot project around
doing interventions within social
housing linking it to a voucher for nrt
through a local pharmacy and there's
also some
um there's a project through Oxford
University that's going to look to do
some research so we've asked them to
just hang fire because it would be great
to be part of this National research
through that project and I think that's
great a great place he's got great
places don't really have that much stock
in traffic compared to others to the
likes of L and Q and your housing group
have got the huge estate in Partington
and oh well Valley you've got to sell
West I think we need to to link with
those and three main ones really I know
what you mentioned on your
um presentation you had housing
representative and I just wondered who
who that was
I think it was somebody from strategic
housing as opposed to a house right okay
I wasn't aware I wasn't aware that we
were part of of that so again
thank you
I'm used to it Jay
a couple of things first on on the verb
pin um point I agree with Richard again
it's not it's not a in Trafford but for
my uh Teenage and uh pre-teen children
vaping is just all over the school those
figures just don't seem to Bear reality
to the way in which it is described uh
the behaviors at the school and it's
young young people so this is year seven
and year eight it's not just all this it
feels like it's kind of starting earlier
than people did used to start uh smoking
I do think that our messages around
vaping and before the health perspective
are quite confusing
because we're saying Vape rather than
smoke I think that's still the message
but we're also saying don't there at all
and I think from from a publicity I
think that is quite I think it's quite
comfy as it mentioned now we get some
clarity
um around that and some understanding of
what the potential Health consequences
uh from vaping may be massive
environmental impact from
um disposable virtual single views I
mean you just see them all over the
place so there's a real environmental
challenge
um for us in a massive plastic cost
we're trying to reduce single-use
plastic obviously but we've got these
things uh all over the all over the
place so I do think that we're willing
to think about that on the smoking side
from sort of from my perspective it's in
a round trading standards so a legal
sale of tobacco to uh under 18s and
um the sale of tobacco that's been
smuggled in we have got limited uh
resources but I think it's how we can
work with colleagues at GMP better
intelligence can we target it uh uh
appropriately properly can we make sure
that we're then getting the right
sentences from that and recognizing The
Links of that potentially into into
other crime and it can be a front and
kind of Link into into other uh crime we
have had some success recently but we
need to do more but it is a big resource
challenge uh for us I think so we
maximize our Collective resources
absolutely and I think a lot of the um
conflicting messaging around Vapes as
well is around uh if you're using a vape
a smart part of a smoking cessation
program that Vape is uh regulated
um it's not the same as the illegal
Vapes uh where there's other substances
within them that that's when you you get
the causing of the of the very um more
serious kind of health concerns it is a
confusing message
um and I think it's not very much helped
by I mean there was pressing over the
weekend wasn't there around
um the call to for for them to be unable
to promote
um single-use Vapes and how they're in
neon colors to attract young people uh
so the so nationally
um I think there is a lot of concern
around how they're being marketed to to
young people which is very very
unhelpful
yeah and it may be that there's some
some lobbying we need to do within
public health and to see it's a national
level around some policy uh legislation
on this it feels a fairly unregulated
sector there are a lot of vape shops uh
around there are a lot of them quite
often in lower value
areas
um but they just pop up and proliferate
and so you know there's a High Street
impact that comes from that as well so
there's a bit of how we join rejointing
things up
I am agreeing with everything that's
been said previously
um in education what what age do
children and young people
um get the positive messages and
understand
um what are the appears and what's right
and what's wrong
um so we've got a program that looks
with year sixes around vaping
um that but not all schools have engaged
within that program uh so it is that is
I would say the starting age and then
obviously we've done significant work
over the past year in trying to get
promotion out
um within the secondary schools we did a
focus group with some young people and
they said those posters around vaping
are everywhere so they are seeing them
and we've got some further work that
we've commissioned through our substance
misuse provider to go in and do some
talks to young people
um giving them the facts around Vapes
um and also also smoking and other kind
of substances that you may be addicted
to like alcohol and do some training
with
um some uh School staff and also youth
work staff
um so but I mean there's so much we we
could do but that's what we've got in in
planned so far okay
um I think sort of supporting the um
whether the data is right
um probably like most organizations and
I won't put our work placement on there
on the spot but we've just had a round
of work placements
um and when the work placements come
into our organization we will ask them
um around their activity levels
um we get them to sort of co-design some
of the things that perhaps we think
differently about and sat here listening
to it I think that the volume of work
placements that will land again next
July and is there a collaboration piece
where you actually talk about a subject
like this and get them to think about
actually what those messages look like
how it could be done from the inside
um out so it was just something
um and then the other one on your slide
previously about the interventions
dropping understandably with resource GP
and Pharmacy just picking up the piece
of work that's taking place in
Partington with and the place based
approach maybe that's something to see
through to the neighborhoods to say
actually could that be done differently
going forward
yeah yeah absolutely I went to the
central neighborhood meeting last week
um and spoke about smoking and said that
maybe this this needs assessment could
be taken around to those neighborhood
meetings because I think that would be
um a key place for them the
interventions are a big concern so we're
trying to look at different ways so um
we've recently started a service uh
particularly focused on people with
mental health needs through a voluntary
sector organization through blue sky so
that they're providing the interventions
and then the pharmacy is just having to
dispense the nrt so we're thinking maybe
that is something that could be expanded
out to or the voluntary sector
organizations
um maybe you know through Leisure and
through um some workplaces in Trafford
we've had some conversations with who
already have like nurses in place within
the workplace so I think
um although it's a shame that we've seen
those interventions drop I think we need
to just be more creative and find some
other ways to
um to let people access smoking
cessation
foreign
Joe's already touched on it Joe came to
the central neighborhood workshop last
week talked a little bit about this
there was so much interest that we've
agreed that would be one of the main
agenda items for the next neighborhood
workshop and I think that's a good
opportunity for us to link in with some
of the housing where you know it's
hosted by RCL West they're quite well
linked into a royal Valley so I think
we've got an opportunity to test some of
the the conversation through the
neighborhood workshops
[Music]
it's been really quick because lots of
my points I've made notes on have been
picked up by others so I think the
Common Thread throughout pretty much
every contribution so far has been about
better and improved communication and
engagement whether that's about
prevention or whether or not whether or
not that's about access to services and
education and so I think that's
something maybe we can take away and
think about how we build that into the
work program of the communications and
engagement work in group that chair
which is meeting this afternoon so I'll
feed that back directly this afternoon
really well really well timed
um so just a commitment to to explore
that and how we can enhance what we're
currently doing
um and then I think the other things
have been picked up around sort of role
of primary care and Pharmacy in
particular educational schools and
checking that we've got that senior
support and networks into education
through the tobacco Alliance so thank
you
uh yeah just a couple of points one
about all the advertising in schools and
stuff around stopping vaping I think uh
they found that um
towards the end of smoking being
advertised that they were actually
putting forward money for the stop
smoking advertising because they found
it made people smoke more so it's like
you've got to be very careful when doing
those things that like you've actually
just getting them in people's minds more
if someone Vapes and they're walking
past posters saying don't they they just
think I need to vape like you know I
mean so it actually triggers the
response rather than fights against it
um also um Canada and Australia have
both taken a very different approach to
the UK around this uh they've equated
vaping with smoking so wherever you
can't smoke you can't vape and they have
like very strict laws around them and
both have much much lower rates so it
might be uh very interesting like just
to look at their different approaches
and how they've gone about it
yeah brilliant I mean I think there's a
whole piece of work that we really need
to do around kind of smoke-free places
smoke-free places need to be Vape free
places as well don't they and so I think
there's a lot of opportunities and
certainly through Partners around this
table around looking at where what
buildings and places within Trafford we
can
um we can inst instill that as a as a
policy and the some of the vaping
Communications around schools
um was around dispelling myths and
giving them some facts around it because
it is it has been interesting when we've
spoken to young people just how I guess
clueless they really are around
um around Vapes and around other
substances so I think the work the early
break are going to be doing in school
will be really helpful in terms of that
education but yeah absolutely take your
point we need to do anything we can to
um stop young people from partaking in
vaping
it might be interesting for the
population Health fellow to look at some
of that kind of data and health
conditions it may not we may not be
seeing it yet but it would be a little
interesting aspect for them to look at
our figures around uh certain young
people's age groups and and conditions
like asthma Etc and see whether have we
seen a bit of a a Rise
um so I'm sure we can incorporate that
yeah just to add in as well that on
Monday there was the great in Manchester
making smoking history strategy kind of
refresh so they've done a draft and they
kind of got everyone in the room to kind
of get their thoughts in it and there
was
um there was some sharing of examples of
kind of other countries so there was
like conversation around that which has
been picked up today but also as well
the kind of lung cancer specialist was
coming in talking about Vapes there so
they have got the kind of different
views so that's going to be it's going
to kind of look at that again another
draft I think that'll be coming out
around September time so just might be
something else to report back next time
in terms of that and it will feed into
our tobacco Alliance as well so just to
add that in there
okay great so um
yes I'm here to give an update on
pharmacies
um basically uh for those of you that
don't know last year we undertook a
pharmaceutical needs assessment in
Trafford which we're required to do
every few years to look at what pharmacy
provision we have got and how good it is
um I'm going to update on Pharmacy
closures and the impact of that talk
about the services that we commission
from public health and then some of the
future developments that we've got on
the cards and so just a reminder
um from trafford's needs assessment we
have 26 pharmacies per 100 000 this is
higher than greater Manchester and
England averages we do dispense fewer
prescriptions
um in terms of nationally we've got
quite a good reach around
um 90.8 of Resident postcodes are within
half a mile of a Trafford Pharmacy
um we are public survey gave good
um feedback in terms of access and then
the needs assessment highlighted the Gap
in provision in Partington and there's
no opening there on a Saturday afternoon
or a Sunday and we have actually tried
to do some some work around the the
pharmacies in that area to see whether
they would be interested in some sort of
a rotor basis but it's very much out of
our control because we don't hold the
contract for pharmacies we only
commission them for for specific
services
we have had some recent closures in
Trafford so as you will know across the
country
um Lloyd's pharmacies have um stopped
providing within Sainsbury's stores So
within Trafford specifically that
affects three of our previous pharmacies
in Altrincham sale and in urmston
um we have looked in public health to
see what alternative nearby provision
there is to see whether we're we're
covered in terms of the hours that they
were offering
generally it's okay we're seeing a
slight reduction in some of those hours
in some of those areas but there still
is pretty good Provisions so I don't
think that is causing us
um potentially as big a concern as the
Gap in Partington is is obviously of
more of interest
um to us and there's also been an
announcement around boots and so boots
are making 300 straw closures and where
there is an alternative within three
miles away so in Trafford
um we have got a boots pharmacy at the
Trafford Center at the urmston retail
Park and at urmston Eden Square so
they're probably all within a one mile
radius of each other so they're all
really near however I would anticipate
um boots are never going to shut the
ones at the Trafford Center or at the
retail park because they will be getting
an extremely good business we also have
altering and Retail Park and altering
and Town Center they will be with in a
three mile and we've also got sail and
Stratford so there is a risk for us and
there's been an announcement of the
eight straws so far for closure in July
none of them are in the Trafford area so
we're just keeping and watching
um eye on it
um really I think that's all we can all
we can do for now
um in Trafford from public health we
commissioned two Services uh from local
pharmacies one is smoking cessation and
one is emergency hormonal contraception
the morning after pill we've made some
changes and we're just redoing contracts
with them at the moment for the pharmacy
offer we used to offer six weeks of
Behavioral support we've increased that
now to 12 to fall in line with the GP
provision
um the E6
um we are establishing as a separate
service following um some advice from
the local pharmaceutical committee I've
already mentioned the nrt voucher so
that might be a really easy way for us
to do some new behavioral support
through other organizations and not
necessarily through Pharmacy
um and uh GP
um there's been some system changes
behind the scenes and we've set up
um some we're giving them 180 pounds for
a new Pharmacy for their setup costs and
to undertake take undertake the training
that is needed to deliver that service
um for EHC
um we have updated what we're expecting
them to do around chlamydia and
gonorrhea screening and making sure that
they're for each young person that's
turning up
um requesting the morning after pill
that they are being given information
about our free screening offer
um we've made some changes there's
there's two generally two types of um
morning after pills that are dispensed
in Trafford so we've the um faculty for
sexual and reproductive Health have
produced some guidelines so we've made
some changes around that
um and there's um pgds are around where
a pharmacy is is doing something that's
um outside of what that drug is
um kind of uh specified for so for
example we've got a pgd in Trafford for
where somebody
um has a higher BMI they can be given a
increased dose of the morning after pill
to ensure that it works effectively and
across these we are doing some
um greater Manchester uh work to quite
to try to standardize
um a lot of these services and we do
have a risk in EHC in Trafford in that
although we've got the guidelines and
we've got a specific spec we have got
some pharmacies that are Distributing
the more expensive drug
um so we've got some budgetary
um pressures there we're just redoing
the contracts at the moment
um 17 of Trafford pharmacies have
returned their contracts out of the 56
so far but we're right in the middle of
the process in terms of developments in
local pharmacy there is the SCS service
which is basically where pharmacies will
take smoking cessation referrals from
hospitals so we've got a cure service in
Greater Manchester which um uses the
opportunity where people are in patients
in hospital to help to use that Health
scare
um to stop them from smoking and then
when they're discharged from hospital
they can be referred straight to
um Community Pharmacy for that continual
support
um you may have heard nationally around
the swap to stop pilot with e-cigarettes
so the deadline for that is the end of
August so we will be looking at what
opportunities we can do to apply for
some of that within Trafford
as with any service but there is a lot
of pressure for local pharmacies there's
been nationally new services that they
brought out where actually new money
hasn't come alongside it so there's been
um they are under a lot of pressure and
we need to make sure that our contracts
are attractive and that they want to do
them
um financially
um uh so that is an area of concern for
us I've mentioned the GM wide
um specifications
um and yeah we for some of those
Services we pay okay compared to other
areas and some of them we pay lower so
um that could have an impact on us
um ideally we want more provision in
Pharmacy to save that GP time
um and then as I mentioned in the
previous
um item we're doing work around that
kind of vouchers through the SMI service
and how housing associations to look
whether we can establish
um vouchers
okay I think that's everything I don't
know if anyone's got any questions on
that one
thanks I think um the difficulty that we
often have in Trafford is that we don't
almost hold those Pharmacy contracts we
we um our influence is only on the
specific services that we uh commission
from them so those kind of broader
issues like that one you described
around the tube I think that it's really
difficult as a local system for us to
look to see how we can support that when
we don't really hold the purse strings
if you know what I mean however some of
the stuff around availability of
medications and that communication
through
um to Primary Care I think certainly
within public health and through the ICB
I think maybe we could be making those
Communications
um from pharmacies information directly
into
um primary care so that may be able to
support with that likewise like we've
had the situation in Partington we've
got relatively few levers that we can
use to influence the hours that
pharmacies want to operate rate and we
can ask we can explain the need but as
their own businesses it's very we
haven't got and because we don't hold
those kind of we don't pay them other
than for these small Services it does
put us in a very difficult situation
certainly around out of hours provision
there's probably some work we can do
collaboratively around Communications
out around what is available but it's
very difficult to influence what they're
actually providing I don't know if
colleagues have got any other
suggestions
I've got a suggestion I'm afraid but I
do think it's a major issue for us and
we've talked about it
I'm old enough to remember the last time
we did this report and it was a problem
then and then if you look at the the
data that we've got from the survey we
know I think it's about one in four
people who live in Partington are
registered disabled many of them will be
needing to have
um access to a pharmacy I know if I'm
talking to some of my gang that work
there that they have a lot of the sort
of what we would call long-term
condition programs that a lot of people
don't Complete because they've got a lot
of other things going on in their lives
which is quite understandable so I just
I think it's a an appeal really about if
there's anything we can actually do
about it at all because I think it's
amazing it must be a major problem for
people
yeah
yeah and two things really one just
um the closure of pharmacies and it's
really obvious on the ground that the um
remaining pharmacies are struggling in
terms of it taking a lot longer for
prescriptions to come through several of
them have started charging for
deliveries to try and cut down how many
patients they're delivering to which is
not ideal we have difficulty getting
um blister packs sometimes for patients
because they'll come to the limit of you
know we can only do so many blister
packs and obviously we only use them for
people where it's the safety issue or it
means that you know so I think that's
and there's all this talk about
pharmacies doing more all the time like
the um consultation scheme when they're
doing blood pressures now and there's
this new plan of they're going to be
able to treat sore throats and things
but they haven't they're struggling for
capacity as much as we are so that's not
really you know that's not really the
answer as far as I'm concerned but the
other thing is I think there is
something missing in all the governance
and things locally of Pharmacy
representation because they're not um
there's not anyone on the locality board
or in any of these things and it's
difficult because they're all
independent even more than GPS are they
all want to you know they're all
independent and they do their own thing
but they do the the local um the LPC
does have a retro PCN so I think we can
maybe look at linking that in better
yeah
thanks I was going to raise the same
issue around capacity so so we've got
the alternative provision you know have
they got the capacity to do it and it
sounds like that some of them are
struggling
just in terms of the local pharmacy
being represented in our governance if
they are a member and do come to the
primary care committee you know I'm in
traffic but I think that does need to be
expanded absolutely because you know
they're a massive piece of what we're
trying to do aren't they so so I think
you're right with that and then just a
quick question Joe and in terms of the
impact it sounds like that it's probably
wider than just the numbers isn't it you
know if they're in some of the sort of
impacts of these closes it's you know
some of the software intelligence so so
do
do we plan to do any more work to
understand what this is or are we going
to wait to the next sort of needs
assessment because because it needs a
bit of unpicking doesn't it rather than
just say well we've you know we've still
got this within three miles so that's
fine
but but really it's clearly not because
you know pharmacies are struggling and
patients are going to struggle as a
result aren't they
I think the needs assessment is um very
kind of specific on what it needs to
cover
um so that is and that won't get
refreshed for of I think it's three
years now
um so I think that's a piece of work to
one to one side now some of these
closures are really really close to
other pharmacies so if you look at
Sainsbury's sale you you're probably
only working walking about 100 meters
maybe not even that to get to Tesco's
Pharmacy so some of them are incredibly
um close together likewise the old
tringum one is really really close to
um the the Tesco's provision so I think
in terms of that impact of the ones that
have closed so far I don't know I don't
know but I'm only guessing I don't know
that there would be a huge other impact
to people in those in those Pharmacy
closures but who knows what's gonna
what's coming up in terms of if we have
a number of Boots close closures some of
those are not necessarily in areas where
there are such close
um pharmacies and alternative provision
so it may be of a bigger
um there may be a bigger impact in in
some of them and I think you're right
there's something and as you're saying
around just capacity of as a whole of
pharmacies that I think there is a piece
of work to do with them to understand
those pressures understand that capacity
and just see whether there's a system if
there is anything we can do to support
it and and I mean I spoke to somebody
from
um yesterday around Pharmacy provision
I'm speaking about smoking cessation
specifically and I said we've seen a
real
um you know reduction
um what do you think we should do in in
Trafford and they were saying that
actually those e-vouchers for dispensing
nrt brilliant she was like that is so
easy for a pharmacy to just dispense
that she went the actual smoking
cessation provision of Behavioral
support they're not going to have
capacity to that you're not going to get
much take up with that but if you can do
develop more services that is just that
voucher you'll get good you'll get good
Provisions so I think we do I mean we
engage with them around our services but
we certainly don't engage with them on
that kind of this bigger issue of
capacity and the role of Community
Pharmacy in the health system
yeah I think the medications is an issue
just to clarify the three miles that's
what boots are saying that they're going
to do their closures on in terms of
Trafford we've got the vast majority of
people within half a mile of a of a
pharmacy
um and almost everybody is within one
mile of a pharmacy so that three mile
figure is only the boots thing the
medication access I mean we've we've had
it within certain Services
um ourselves like champix um for smoking
cessation which has been unavailable
um but I think there is something and I
don't know
um how we do that piece of work uh but
maybe we need to link in with the LPC to
discuss it because I think that
yeah I think it's probably worth the
conversation at GM level because they're
the closest to to the pharmaceutical
contract uh discussion it's got
something
that perhaps we can have a conversation
it might change in the future that could
be an issue for the locality in the
future but at the moment it's it's a GM
so
people take an action to have a
conversation around the con because I
think that probably does happen to the
pharmacist but whether that feeds
through in the regular bulletins to
primary care I don't know I suspect it's
probably not as good as it could be so
it's maybe not something we could do
yes yeah
time yeah I was just going to say Joe is
your team keyed into the work stream
groups for the love funding in
poundington
because if not I think that's the
opportunity as well to just perhaps
the whole Pharmacy I'm not quite sure
how that progresses forward but some of
those other services looking differently
there's a governance model in place for
that Partington which would come online
in 2025 and I think that could be an
opportunity to look differently
we have got a member of our team that's
the kind of neighborhood lead for the
for the West area so we'll make sure
that she's Linked In with that if she's
not already
unfortunately we were helping to bring a
paper
um to the board today
um so the BET care fund joint fund
um with two elements the back care fund
itself improved Back Care funds uh
between the ICB and Trafford and traffic
Council there is a requirement
um to submit a template with sporting
narrative to NHS England which we did do
on the 28th of June
um unfortunately we we were requested to
to make some um points of clarification
to to that submission hence it not
coming to the board today and that work
has been done the deadline for
submission of um the the responses to
the clarifications was yesterday in
which we met and we're pretty confident
we've met that in full
um so what we will be doing is bringing
the final version when we've received
nhse sign off
um to to the next committee
um important to know that the activity
around the better care fund carries on
you know obviously I should be um
Council continuing to to deliver the
core functions under the fund and the
section 75 agreement
um is ready for Signature I'm just
waiting for that nhse ratification and
that can be processed so as soon as we
get um word from nhsc we're good to go
okay I'm not gonna um do long on this at
all because I won't do it anything like
the justice that Bernie will do and
obviously I'm relatively new to Trafford
so
um I've been learning a bit about what's
gone on so far uh in the last um kind of
year or so and
um it feels like a really yeah as you
say kind of powerful movement that has
started to get going and I suppose we
just wanted to come today to quickly
share with you
um for anyone who wasn't involved or
isn't familiar the kind of background
um which has been kind of bubbling
around and what Bernie's been leading on
that really kind of Grassroots level and
getting
um people to think about and share their
experiences and start to harness that
and so the journey so far and some of
the next steps and I suppose we're
really Keen to hear your thoughts
um and insights from what you've gone
before and also ideas of course for
helping us in the future
um so the context a little bit of
context for this from a kind of I
suppose more
um National looking perspectives
hopefully you're all aware that there
was National Women's Health strategy
came out in July 22
um which was as it says there really
about resetting the dial on women's
health and I think just really opening a
lot of eyes to issues that um had been
under the radar or a bit Cinderella
service or kind of not not at the
Forefront of everybody's mind in terms
of particularly looking at the NHS
Services although it's worth noting that
um the strategy also talks about uh kind
of the implications for women who've
experienced violence and abuse in terms
of their health services and their care
and their experiences generally so
hopefully you've kind of felt this in
the in the
um in the kind of national dialogue as
well I think we've seen a slightly more
increased talk about things that affect
women particularly
um but a big part of that strategy was
you was that it was built on the um
experiences of women who were brave
enough to share their experiences
something we've probably been trying to
share their experiences for many many
years
um and so giving that uh those stories
of voice to make some changes
um as you'll see uh some of the things
up there about the effect that it had on
people's health and quality of life and
how often people felt women felt ignored
or not listened to when they were trying
to seek that help so if you go to the
next slide Bernie very quickly these are
the areas that are specifically
um mentioned uh covered sorry in the
national health strategies you'll see
it's you know it's about particular
health issues and how they present for
women and women's experiences or
Services
um but obviously in looking to address
these to look at the full range of
experiences women have in our society
and our neighborhoods and the
differences that different women
experience
um so that's the kind of um broader
context
um there's a GM
um group and strategy I think that's
been that's Al that looked at this but I
think the kind of real push from
Trafford is recognizing that we're a bit
started on this and we've started
already thinking about what women have
experienced a need and the power that
they've got in in trafford's women's
voices so really kind of not waiting for
things to come from the top this is a
hook it's an obvious opportunity to use
some of the experiences people share
with us to make real changes and there's
certainly something for this board and
the locality Board of course and all of
us are on the table to think about how
we do that within our own services and
as a system but I suppose the focus
today is really how do we continue to
um give the right um space and platform
and empowerment to women to continue to
share their voices so that we can
continue to make those improvements and
that's what that slide's really about
Helen wanted me to to uh note for
anybody who didn't obviously see it that
those are the suffragette colors that
she's used there I didn't totally spot
that
um so uh yeah and this is just that that
I've said really that
um the focus for us at the moment I
think is to continue in you to allow
that Groundswell to to happen and but
our job I suppose around the table is
people in positions of kind of relative
formal powers to make sure that we are
listening and to encourage those those
um those voices and those movements make
sure that they're plugged in and I
suppose that's why I'm here with Bernie
today although she could have obviously
given you the full thing herself but
Public Health we're trying to offer some
support uh to Bernie and to other
colleagues who've been involved from
various um partners and organizations on
the ground and obviously the residents
who've been involved so far and we I
suppose see ourselves as a bit of a
coordinating force and a bit of a way to
bring it to people like yourselves and
Boards like this
um to keep make sure we can
um keep it keep it moving and use use
what comes out of it uh so I'll hand
over to Bernie I think the next one and
let her give you a much better story
you're doing a good job wrapping it up
anyway because later I think you yeah
we've talked about it haven't we as well
so exactly as you say kind of um uh how
to move it on and to come back in in the
end of the year with something to that
really reinforces it so yeah as you're
saying and I suppose it's just the on
the four recommendations behind you so
um when we've been talking about the
power the power pledge Bernie described
in sort of as a way of getting some
engagement early on and was thinking
about sending this out to you know wider
networks but actually when we thought
about coming to the to the health and
wellbeing board we thought well if we
can say the health will be on board kind
of like that approach and agree to that
those kinds of words
um and sort of endorse it if you like
then that helps us when we're sending it
out I suppose to send it wider whether
or not we want to say that as well being
able to signs up I think it's probably
more powerful but but you know more
helpful we were talking about it if it's
individuals who can then contribute to
things so both kind of Staff who are
working in those whether they work in
neighborhood teams or whether they work
in a more Trafford or Beyond kind of way
because some of our teams will not work
in individual neighbors will they
um but also obviously um services and
then some of us who have those more
strategic roles to sort of say that
we'll support it and that might allow
for some of those models of
um mental embodying those kind of things
that I think have been learned from so
that was all I think I was going to say
at the end
I'm really sorry because I've got to go
to other meeting in a moment I think
like other colleagues but I think that
was absolutely fantastic great
presentation and um I just think we
really need to spend some time thinking
about how we can get these women's
voices into the work we're doing partly
through the neighborhood work but I'm
really interested in
I'll catch up with you later about what
we can do within the lco I certainly
know Nathan
um and Katie's Chief exec will be very
keen to think about supporting the next
work you know the next event as well
well there you go so yeah so I think
that would be brilliant but thank you
very much I should say I definitely want
to support it and I suppose my question
is how how do we um promote it and just
get it out there beyond the existing
networks really because it's really
really powerful stuff
no no one has come through